hello reject nation
I'm Greg Alba who is what's what's your
name what's Mexican man i'm sammy
gonzales a k mexican man mmm excellent
from double toasted ah sitcom toast calm
if you guys have ever seen double
toasting you might have caught sammy on
some of those videos over there Sammy I
actually actually met a long time ago
when John and I were on Collider video
showdown yeah we went up against double
toasted and I think we're not to have a
beer with Cory and Martin I spend
majority of my time talking with you
[Applause]
visiting LA for a day right now so I was
like Sammy you gotta come on the channel
here you got to do that cross promotion
that cross promotion go watch double
toasted people Sammy have you heard of
this movie called an infinity war
Avengers what Avengers infinity war
starring Batman 2 TV spots we got a lot
of requests to check out one is called
Thanos snaps his fingers never one is
legacy so many requests I'm sure we're
probably gonna get maybe five seconds of
new footage yeah but it's gonna be worth
it
Oh cease to exist
in time to see all the possible outcomes
did we win anything Wow that
to salvation
Avengers infinity war with a pg-13
everywhere April 27th well he didn't
snap his fingers no he just kind of
dropped it on again he's just ready to
do it they did reveal one plot point
here they talk about Doctor Strange
going forward in time and I haven't
heard any of that yet that this movie
will do that where he says he goes
forward in time has some outcomes and I
think that's cool to include that in the
movie here some of that time-traveling
stuff so I'm excited about that actually
I gets me a little bit more intrigued by
it yeah there's a little more uh what's
her name Scarlet Witch in there too
doing a little bit more stuff you know
that's snapping of the fingers that
might be a thing you know
Chamorro with him is gonna be a
flashback when she was young so at some
point he's gonna snap we're gonna die
it's gonna be actually scary the thing
about Thanos though is with the Infinity
Gauntlet he could kill everyone with a
snap of his fingers well I mean that
would be a really climatic ending right
it's like yeah just oh yeah they're all
dead face for your Rico they missed out
they missed the bus let's watch the
legacy one really quick because this one
this one's the really requested one okay
who might show they're good the big
baddies the group of baddies black order
black oh that's racist
or they're the dark order okay maybe the
dark I think with Black Panthers success
they won't be like oh you have the black
order they're the bad guys now whoa
they're low snap better bring together
this is everything a nurse is seeing
right here
[Music]
the end is near Avengers infinity war 27
now they're really capitalizing on what
are you doing that's the actual clip he
puts in the stone i watch this 20 minute
video the other day called the road to
infinity war which is just this giant
edit of all the movies put together and
just seeing this - really does put you
back in that mindset of like oh sure
yeah I've been invested yeah I was in
high school and now I'm going to my ten
year anniversary reunion for high school
I was a different human being I just
grew this beard over the last row still
a virgin I definitely was still Origen
nice I still might be it's gonna happen
brand new legacy today what's going on
here star-lord I kind of just like
scroll through one brief moment does
that start wait a minute that was an
accident what we just that's definitely
star-lord
it looks like star-lord and Iron Man are
fighting with each other here I've never
seen this moment before so he's holding
the arm with this head with his top hand
bending it shut his arms broken in every
situation backward and his shoulders are
facing us maybe Thanos is using the mine
stone to manipulate them to fight
against each other right how
heartbreaking would that be if we get
our heroes to kill off one of the other
heroes start or just dies
Sammy thanks for being here of course
there you have your first video guys you
can subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification Belka subscribe
buttons don't work you can check out
Sammy on his Instagram Twitter at than
excellence but also check them out
on double toasted they are a fantastic
YouTube channel yes it is a great
channel go check them out as soon as you
can
link in my description box